all right before we dive into this
episode the minimalist want to help you
declutter your glowing screen so head on
over to the minimalists comm slash
wallpapers to download any of our free
minimalist wallpapers including our love
people use things wallpaper for your
smartphone or computer enjoy
and minimalists hello everybody welcome
to the minimalist podcast where we
discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua Fields Milburn my name is Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalist today we're gonna talk about
career advice we're gonna talk about
pursuing your passions we're gonna talk
about mentors we're gonna talk about
stepping stones the stepping stones to
success we're gonna talk about a whole
lot more with Ken Coleman he's our guest
today is the author of the proximity
principle which I'll hold up if you're
watching this on youtube you can check
that out ken thank you for joining us
today
Josh Ryan we are happy to have you man
I'm stoked about this it's gonna be fun
so so the folks who listen to this know
weird weird giant fans of the the whole
ramsey team and this is the only ramsey
personality who has not been on our show
I think and some people don't know what
to make of that they've laughed you a
couple times Rachel's been on twice and
Anthony's gonna be on again
I got to step it up here this the
pressures on this is gonna be great now
the full so we're gonna dive into some
listener questions here I really I
wanted to real quick talk about your
book the proximity principle because
Ryan and I often have this line we talk
about proximity is actually a problem in
in many respects but you address the
problem with proximity you're fighting
fire with fire in a way so what I often
say is most of our relationships in our
life are birthed out of convenience and
proximity and so we hang out with people
who happen to work in the cubicle next
to us or we grew up in the same
neighborhood together but we don't share
the same values beliefs interest desires
goals objectives in life and so you know
there's obviously the saying of you who
was it was it was a Zig Ziglar or
someone like that who and I know you
actually talked about it in your book
but you are the the Jim Rohn Jim right
what the average of the five people you
spend the most time with right right and
so right now we we have access to more
more people than ever but we're stuck in
proximity to the sort of people around
us and in the book you talk about well
you talk about proximity being proximity
to people proximity to place and then
you
also talked about a very important step
there's also a lot of hard work involved
and so can we can we sort of talk real
quick about you delineate in the book
between environmental peers versus
intentional peers yes
well I'm so glad you brought this up
because the the scene that you set for
us all is absolutely spot-on and what's
missing in the scene that you pay
painted for us is intentionality because
the what I mean by environmental peers
are these are the people that you are
just by your natural just this is where
you are in life okay this is what you
inherit right so these are the peers and
we're talking about family and friends
that are around you by just the nature
of your current station so that's
environmental so as you say we grow up
with them we go to school with them we
see them over the summer time whatever
that is but and then when we look at the
intentional peers this is where we
decide hey these are the people that I'm
choosing to be around right okay now
what's interesting is there's a choice
you know in just stayin with the
environment that you're in
yeah hey well this is just and most
people do this why it's the easy thing
to do well it's even deeper than that
what's that it's safe yeah it is throaty
yeah and so there it is so because it is
safe and it's certain right because
uncertainty is our greatest fear yeah
I'm telling you right now you go look it
up I'm not the only person to say this
the unknown is the greatest fear that
humans face greatest fear now so in my
environment it's safe because it's
certain and then it makes it easy right
but for me to change
oh now things get to be difficult just
by virtue of facing the emotion of
choosing to be around different people
let's talk about what that looks like
well if you choose to stop hanging out
with people that you've been in
relationship with well now that hurts
their feelings yeah they get mad they
start to question why are you doing this
they poopoo the choices that you're
making and there's tremendous pressure
for you to not make the change that you
know in your head
and your heart that you need to make and
so the delineation there in the book is
okay this is environmental and then here
this is intentional here and so we've
got to make the intentional choices to
be around the people that are going to
lift us push us and hold us accountable
we talked about that the actual that's
one of the five people in the book is
the peer so that's the difference and
some of us are blessed to have
environmental peers that need to stay in
our lives right all right now that's my
particular journey hmm but there are
some that I had to leave behind yeah and
that's painful for both parties by the
way absolutely in the day you got one
life and it's your life to live not the
life that they want you to live yeah I
think what happens is we often end up
getting dragged in other people's
directions if if we allow that to happen
no question yeah think about it
we're all spinning around each other
right and so you're hanging around the
wrong people they pull you into their
orb and and so now you're just kind of
rotate that's what that's what Rona
talking about let me give you some more
data on this okay Jim runes right but
how about the most story the most
impressive historic relationship study
in history by the University of Harvard
I mean hard Harvard University it's over
80 years old okay and they keep
iterating on this study on the power of
relationships in our lives and one of
the leading sociologists in that study
at Harvard has said not his name escapes
me right now but he has said that 95
percent of our success or failure is
predicated on the people we hang around
with that is mind boggling yeah yeah we
often like to take full credit for
everything that we do and of course
blame everyone else for any of any of
the failures but ultimately what you're
saying is it's up to me to surround
myself with with the people who are
going to empower me people who are going
to inspire me or motivate me it's it's
up to me to to find those those
intentional peers as opposed to being
dragged in the direction of the
environmental peers oh I'm alone we've
got some questions here today our first
question is from Melissa
Delaware hi guys my name is Melissa I'm
from Milford Delaware and my question
pertains to passion and finding a job to
pay the bills and I am passionate about
the current job I have however some of
their daily tasks don't really line up
with my values related to the field and
I don't feel inspired anymore by the job
and I feel very bored when I go there
and I nobody's teaching me anything
anymore so I would like some advice on
how to find another job that can pay the
bills even though you're not inspired by
the current one your aim however the
current when your aim is providing you
with the highest pay at the time so I'm
just looking to continue doing my
passion and stay inspired as well as pay
the bills
and I can't really find a balance to do
both alright so can you you address this
a lot on your radio show the Kim Coleman
show appropriately named-- yeah yes I'm
highly creative I want to point that out
we spent days and days coming up with
that name I focus groups and so I I
think can your your best equipped to
answer this question because Melissa is
in a situation right now where she's she
has a job to pay the bills and as Dave
Ramsey writes in the foreword to your
book that's a blessing
that you have the ability to pay your
bills but it doesn't mean you have to
stay there forever necessarily yeah well
it's interesting she started out to call
Melissa said I'm passionate about the
work but then she kept delineating and
it sounded as though she was a
passionate so I want to point out to the
rest of the listeners here at what you
really should be hearing in what she
said what she said was I'm bored mmm
that's what she said yeah she said I'm
not learning anything and she also
pointed out I have a problem with the
some of the things they do there's no
value in it now first as I heard that I
said well is this a is this a value
conviction issue it's not what you're
hearing Melissa say is I'm not
challenged anymore I'm not learning when
she says I'm not learning anything this
is one of the five causes of build up on
the heart okay I don't
that burnouts a thing now burnout has
been named very recently by the World
Health Organization as a medical
condition I think it's a bunch of hooey
because it's not a medical condition are
some of the things that result in the
way you're feeling do they cause medical
things yes but we can't treat buildup on
the heart with a pill right okay now so
what I would tell Melissa is okay good
news you know the work that you really
enjoy doing she says that right in the
first 10 seconds of the call so now we
want to identify other opportunities so
this is gonna be outside of her
organization she has hid her lid I don't
think that there is a ladder for her in
her current organization so that is one
of the first clear signs at it's time to
start looking outward so what is she
looking for she's looking for something
that will be very similar to the work
that she has been doing but it comes
with greater challenges new challenges
is the first thing she's looking for the
second thing she's looking for is a
organization that presents a ladder to
her and what I mean by that is they are
known for two key things number one they
develop their people and as a result of
developing their people they promote
their people that's what she needs to
look for and by the way it's out there
yeah so this is not a new career
necessarily it's not a complete
direction change it's just looking at
okay what do I do best and she knows
what she does best she's a rock star
that's why she's outgrown her current
position and her leaders our poor
leaders they haven't noticed that this
is a woman who needs a challenge who has
mastered her position and she needs more
so she wants to make sure that she is
very clear on this is what I do best
these are my talents strengths and
skills and then she goes okay I love
this work two years ago or a year ago
and so what are the elements in the day
that I love that gives me the juice as I
like to say and when she can identify
those two things she's retreating to
clarity which I talked about the sweet
spot you use what you do best to do what
you love to do most she gets that
clarity and now she knows what she's
looking for and she goes and looks for
it she does not leave this job right
until the other jobs ready to go and
then she says hey love you all
appreciate you it's time for me to move
on I was thinking about - like if she's
real
good at what she does if she is a rock
star for her company she can you know
get clear on you know how that perfect
job looks she can go to her boss and she
could even maybe suggest like hey I know
that what I'm doing right now is X Y & Z
I would like to add in a B or C and
here's why here's that here's the
additional value that I'm going to add
to the company so I totally agree she
doesn't have to totally leave her job
right now she can she could maybe
manipulate a little bit what she's doing
right now I do want to say if you know
she's you know it has to kill puppies
every day I'll leave the job like that's
going against your values but but I
agree with you it doesn't sound like it
was really going against our values as
much as she is board and I think you
know burnout I I agree I think it's kind
of hooey yeah I think what happens
though with with us humans we our brains
get we get bored when we master
something that's right and when we met
she is a master at her job right now so
our mind automatically wants to learn
other things and there's nothing wrong
with that she could I you know to me
like I always go to giving like I'll go
to if I start to feel bored or I start
to feel like I'm not growing like I go
to a soup kitchen I'll sign up for
Habitat for Humanity I'll just walk down
the street by homeless people MIT's like
just something to make me feel like I'm
contributing beyond myself in a
meaningful way so I guess another
another suggestion for Melissa here is
try to find something maybe outside of
your job where you can contribute and
you can feel like you are growing you
don't necessarily have to grow with your
job per se you can grow in other areas
of your life and that might fulfill the
need there's a lot of you know ideas and
suggestions here Melissa try them all
out and see what works best now can you
you and your book talk about mentors and
it sounds to me like she probably does
if she does have a mentor she's outgrown
the mentor in a way and can we talk a
little bit about that about the need for
having a mentor and what she's pursuing
this new job this new career it sounds
to me like she probably also needs to
pursue the appropriate mentor well we
all need mentors so this is not just a
Melissa thing this is a an everybody
thing and here's why in this moment of
uncertainty you know and she's feeling
you can tell
you could hear there's some there's some
just natural anxiety built up there
about what's next where do I go how do I
go all this kind of stuff and having
that mentor somebody who is older has
more experience has some knowledge and
has wisdom and when you can sit down
with them okay here's where I am here's
here's what's going on here's why it's
feeling this way I feel like I want to
go this direction not sure you're able
to be totally vulnerable and transparent
and then that mentor is able to very
objectively process all that coming back
and they're also known for at least
knowing us well enough to where we know
they care for us and they're gonna give
us some truth it's not gonna always be
what we want to hear but it's what we
need to hear and in this situation it's
wonderful to have a sounding board
sometimes just to give us perspective
that it's not as bad as we think
in my journey there were many times
where I felt like I wasn't gonna be able
to hang on there was tremendous doubt
because I was going into broadcasting
it's a very difficult world to make it
in very very very difficult very
political it's just tough the changing
landscape well yeah a lot of people were
finding in all of their careers now the
landscapes are shifting really rapidly
yeah and there were times where I almost
quit and it was a call to a mentor in
Houston Texas another mentor in Seattle
Washington those two men multiple times
kept me in the game by simply being
there hearing me kind of vetch a little
bit and kind of complain and talk about
how down I was and just didn't see it
and blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah you know human éor and they
were my tickers and they were like six
months ago you know chewed your right
leg off to be where you are now you've
had some good things happen it's not
happening the way you wanted to or as
fast as you want to but you got to stay
with it you're not delusional you're
gonna make it but you got to stay that
was a game changer for me
that's great Melissa I won't add one
more thing so Melissa talks about the
money factor and how if she could jump
to a different job that'd be great but
well what she's doing right now is it's
paying the bills and she's making a
certain amount of money this is where
minimalism comes in I mean when
when I got laid off when Josh quit what
do we make like 23,000 bucks that year
yeah and if I if I hadn't simplified my
life and prepared for that that leap
then yeah I would be in a world of hurt
so I guess just anyone out there who has
that particular problem where they're
scared to make less money you can
totally find ways oh it takes a plan
it's not like you can just turn on a
switch and tomorrow boom I can make
$10,000 less a year but you can make a
plan you pay off debt save some money
get you know six months worth of savings
to the point where you could make this
leap and maybe make a little bit less
for that first year just so you can have
that perfect job cuz Melissa if there's
a job sitting right now that she's
looking at she's like god I would be so
thrilled to do this job and it's really
really what I want but the money's not
there that is that is a hurdle that you
can absolutely get over since it's not
easy but you absolutely can get over
that well and let me just add real quick
to it don't assume that there's not
something out there that pays the same
or more absolutely now so let's go do
our homework let's go do some research
don't just assume that's one of the
things people do a lot and I just I got
to tell you don't you know just because
it's safety it's it's it's like even
though she may not be making millions of
dollars this is still the idea of the
golden handcuffs you know we're we're so
scared to just even look for heaven
sakes we didn't say leap we said look
right the phrase says look before you
leap and I also want to say a big big
big amen to what you just said on
minimalism this idea that you're not
gonna have to give up something to move
up is insane there will be times in your
life many times you will have to give up
to move up yeah so in this situation it
might be I'm gonna have to give up some
of my luxuries which means I'm gonna cut
cut cut cut cut and change my lifestyle
to change my future I love that Sean you
can tweet that sometimes you have to
give up to move up that's great man one
other thing you can tweet this is a
quote from his book it's no one is
sitting around thinking about how they
can help you find your dream
that's not that's not just for Melissa
that's for anyone to think about you you
we we often get stuck on our heads and
we think that well everyone's thinking
about me and how they can help me
succeed but the truth is they're not
unless I'm gonna send you a copy of the
proximity principle I think you really
enjoy it I got a lot out of it this is
really the book I wish I could have
given to my 18 year old self or my 24
year old self well I'm gonna give it to
some friends and family right I got one
family member who I was talking about
here's kind of the steps you need to
take and they literally said unless
someone hands me the perfect job I'm
just gonna stay where I'm at and I enjoy
sitting still for a long time Melissa
I'm also gonna send you a copy of our
book minimalism live a meaningful life
it's the first book that Ryan and I
wrote but there is an entire chapter in
there about passion and and how you
shouldn't confuse excitement with
passion right now I know you're dealing
with some boredom issues and I think
that passion chapter will will help
illuminate the path forward for you so
if you like our podcast you're like the
audiobook version of minimalism live a
meaningful life or if you want the book
book or the e-book we're happy to send
those to you as well Ryan what time is
it you know what time it is it's time
for our lightning round where we answer
questions from social media dee we do we
are at the minimalists on Facebook
Twitter and Instagram we have at Ken
Coleman here as well
you can reach out to him on Twitter
follow him and so what we try to do here
Ken is we try to answer questions and
short shareable less than 140 character
responses oh but not really
we just ramble on it's a nice challenge
and then what happens is is podcast
Shawn tweezers them out the beautiful
pithy remarks out and we call them
minimal Maxim's and we count along all
of our minimal Maxim's over at minimal
Maxim's com Ryan what's the first
question the first question is from
Caitlyn how do you make your dream job
come true when you have too much
competition to compete with in that
field Josh could you imagine if we let
that stop us from creating our website I
mean how many how many minimalism blogs
were there yeah I mean thousands and
that that's the thing and think about
with with Dave Ramsey he's not the first
person to ever give financial advice or
think about this book so Seth Godin
wrote about this recently so
if you're selling the proximity
principle where do you want to sell it
you you probably want to sell it at a
bookstore and not at the the the Exxon
Mobil gas station on the corner well but
there's no competition there's no
competition at all at the Exxon Mobil
gas station but you're more likely to
sell this book at a bookstore where
there is competition why is that well
because people show up people show up at
the bookstore they've already made the
decision I want to buy a book the
question now is which book do I want to
buy which one's going to add the most
value to my life and so I would argue
the competition especially friendly
competition like that I mean there's a
there's such a thing as toxic
competition for sure they can get in the
way but but friendly competition is
actually a good thing
katelyn so Ken how does she make her her
dream job come true when there's so much
competition in that field there's only
one you and you were created to fill a
unique role that means that you were
needed and you must do it somebody out
there needs you to be you stop competing
and start contributing yes start
contributing it's great you know what
I'm saying yeah dude makes the ideas her
mindset needs to change
100% don't compete against everybody
else compete against yourself
you're the best you yeah that's actually
my pithy answer is if you want to if you
want to grow compete with the best
version of yourself so I am I'm 38 years
old now right now and I am most inspired
by my 45 year old self like because I
want to be the best version of myself
seven years from now right and I think
the same should be true for all of us we
should aspire to be the best version of
ourselves yeah my pet the answer is
adding value begets value and I got a
little aside the best way to add value
is to contribute so the thing is is with
Josh and I when we started the
minimalists calm we didn't just copy
what everyone else did we added value in
that field in a unique way and anyone
can do that and you know sometimes that
doesn't mean like you have to have your
own unique spin on it you can just you
can just go to a company and offer to
get coffee for free and just find a way
to contribute towards a company one
work for it and there may be a thousand
people applying but if you can find one
way to contribute that no one else is
contributing they're going to they're
gonna notice that and they're going to
appreciate that it's wrong you talk
about internships in in your book and
we're gonna talk a little bit more about
that but I think some people are
allergic to this this idea of like
taking a step back in order to actually
step in the right direction can we talk
about internship yeah
yeah and I use that word loosely because
some of your illustrate going Ken I'm 32
I'm 35 I'm 42 and 45 I'm not gonna
intern well why not because I was 32 and
I interned by simply showing up one day
at the number one sports talk station in
Atlanta were talking about at number
eight market so this is a big city big
opportunity and I walked in off the
street and asked to speak to the program
director he didn't know me from Adams
housecat and the girl at the front desk
thought I was nuts but I went in and
said listen I knew his name and we had a
mutual connection so I dropped the
mutual connections name and said I'm out
here and I just want two minutes of his
time and I'll literally put myself on a
stopwatch and she relayed the message to
him and he showed up and he kind of
looked at me like I had four ears but I
smiled big I wasn't a nut job
I dropped the mutual connection he told
me to drop by I just wanted two minutes
don't even have to go back to the office
I just want to help out around here
I want to get into broadcasting I'm
successful at my own company I'm not
gonna ask you for a nickel but is there
any way that I can just hang around and
be of service stay from underfoot you
know but just help what is the guy gonna
say that right he was like oh okay but
we did it and so for three days a week
for three hours a day I was in their
screen and phone calls getting sprite
four guys that were on the air that
weren't even making as much as I was why
do I tell that story to illustrate what
I'm writing about in the book which is
the idea of interning simply means
showing up for free volunteering your
time to get in proximity why well number
one you get to get in there and you're
in the middle of the place that you
think you want to end up being in and so
what am i doing I'm clarifying that yes
this is something I think I'd like to do
and that verifies the feeling in the
heart so we want to clarify in order to
verify that we're not nuts that we
really are wanting to pursue this this
stirs our heart the best place to do
that is show up and work for free
because it's really hard for people to
say no to that
yeah and so it's just simple simple
strategy here that works and that's what
I'm talking about
and again I've done it yeah and and it
is the way to get in you know and
sometimes it's not even doing anything
just say can I just shadow right well
you say in the book the the line that
stood out to me is practice doesn't pay
well no it does and but that's not the
point of practice right you're not
practicing so that amazed you you are
practicing so that you are honing your
skills you're getting better you're
growing you're learning so that you can
use those skills in the future to
contribute in a way that will ideally
pay you yeah I got a line here I got to
drop it yeah you inspired me a practice
doesn't pay well but it always ages well
yeah what I mean by that is that is a
great ROI it will return it doesn't
always return quickly but I'm telling
you right now I'm doing things on the on
the air every day that I learned in
those really humble moments of just
watching other people and just kind of
wishing I was at the party but I wasn't
at the party I was outside looking in
watching everybody party but sometimes
being close enough to look in the window
is all you need yeah that experience is
priceless well yeah yeah I totally agree
MK wants to know how do you ask someone
to be a mentor so we touched on on
mentorship a little bit my pithy answer
is asked not what you can get ask what
you can give yeah and I think that's
that's the thing when we show up
somewhere it is very much like okay
here's what I need you to give to me
well it's like I've never met you why
would I do that but you when you showed
up to the radio station you said how can
I serve you how can I be of service and
if you're asking that question I think
you're gonna you're gonna end up with a
better answer yeah my answer on this is
let's stop making the mentor this
hard-to-reach soothsayer on the top of a
very difficult mountain to climb okay
let's stop making at that the Sherpa I
love the Sherpa everybody needs a Sherpa
but you're
Sherpa might be somebody that you've
known for 30 40 years it's just a
successful man or woman who in their own
field different field in your field but
they've just done life well and they've
got wisdom they have compassion for you
they're on your team let's stop making
this such a difficult person to find
it's not so it needs to be somebody that
you already know or be you have a mutual
relationship and they grease the wheels
for you to where it is not this cold
call it's not this out-of-left-field
thing and then here's how you approach
them this is so ridiculously simple but
it works nine times out of 10 and when
it doesn't work you know that's not the
right person anyway so nine times out of
10 this works number one you want to
show tremendous humility by saying hey
you're where I would like to be you're
just you're there and I admire you and
as a result I would like to learn from
you and I would be incredibly grateful I
don't want to eat up a lot of your time
I'll do it on your schedule whenever and
I time together is about me bringing
scenarios learning best practices just
learning things from you and where I
need to go next what you would recommend
I do to continue to grow and hold me
accountable to the things we talk about
that's what I'd like to happen and I
would be blown away and incredibly
grateful if if you would consider this
now let me tell you something you
approach people like that they get value
by feeling valuable so people go what I
have nothing to give garbage yes you do
you can give the feeling of being
valuable and I don't care how successful
you are everybody loves to give their
opinion
and everybody loves to feel valuable
yeah so if you do that nine times out of
ten they're gonna say yep and I'm doing
that right now with a guy that we had a
mutual relationship didn't know me at
all been a mutual relationship the
mutual relationship sent a text to this
guy he's almost seven years old he does
life coaching and career coaching for
seven figure earners okay he's behind
the scenes like he'd never know him he's
a freakin rock star okay and he's
forgotten more about coaching people
than I know at this point and I'm 45
and I've got a national program and so
I've got to make sure that I'm
sharpening myself all the time
that I'm being filled up from somebody
who's got way more than I do and so I
approach this guy that way and he was
like Ken I'd love to fit you in my
schedule
he's a busy dude he doesn't need this
but it's game changing right now for me
you wouldn't believe how it's filling me
up and pushing me and challenging me so
I just want people to know that I've
done what I'm preaching and it works and
people will say yes to that yeah
absolutely but my pity answer is
contributing to a person's life is the
best way to get their attention so it's
kind of similar what we were talking
about with Caitlyn I mean if you're
really really trying to get someone's
attention you're sending them an email
they won't give you the two minutes
they're you know you're tweeting them
they're not tweeting you back find a way
to add value to that person's life I was
thinking about Jess Williams when when I
was thinking about this question she
does all of our social media for us and
she had reached out to me in an email
years back just something simple like
hey you know my husband and I were
photographers you guys are coming to Los
Angeles we would love to take some
pictures for your event would you be
down for that like yeah absolutely so
she came out took some great hurmat took
some great pictures sent him to us we
you know became friends on Twitter but
then all of a sudden we had this need
for a social media manager she's the
first person to pop into my head because
I know how she manages her own social
media I know her photography skills so I
went to Josh I'm like dude let's look at
this Jess Williams a gal like maybe she
might be someone who could do this work
for us and actually when I think about
it Podcast Shawn I mean he was editing
our stuff when we first started you
think about Shawn mihalick who doesn't
do anything for this anymore but how to
write better last night okay yeah so so
like all these people that we have a
part of our circle with the minimalists
com it all started with them just giving
a little bit to us to to to get our
attention basically but I you know I get
asked a lot hey can you do this for me
can you do that for me and it's like I
would love to say yes to everybody but
no I can't do that for you I'm sorry
right the only thing I'll add to this is
sometimes you can be both a mint tea and
a mint or there's someone Ryan and I
a relationship like that where where our
you know it's sort of yin and yang so
our our strong suit for one person will
be a weakness for the other and and so I
actually have a friend as well Chris
Kelly from nourish balance thrive who is
very much a mentor with a lot of health
stuff for me but I've been a mentor for
him with certain business aspects that
that I've been able to help him out with
and and so you can get and give by the
way that's how every great relationship
tends to work anyway yeah absolutely
all right before we dive into our added
value segment and our listener tips and
tricks this week it looks like we've got
a bunch more surprise questions today
including how can I figure out what I'm
passionate about is it possible to
change careers without going back to
square one what are the important things
to keep in mind when freelancing how can
I pursue my dream job if it involves
taking a pay cut how do you advance your
career without overworking yourself and
so much more career advice with Ken
Coleman today and if you wanna hear all
that you can listen to this week's
maximal episode available exclusively on
patreon that's right you're currently
listening to our weekly minimal episode
but each week Ryan and I record an
entirely different much much much much
much longer maximal episode on the
minimalist private podcast plus patreon
is the best way for us to fund this
podcast keep it 100% advertisement free
when you subscribe to the minimalist
private podcast on patreon you'll
receive a personal link so that our
maximal episodes play in your favorite
podcast app you can find all the details
and all the good stuff over at the
minimalists comm slash support Ryan what
else you got for us this week being
informed is more important than ever so
I just want to encourage our readers our
readers and our listeners to read more
and get informed and you can do that by
reading ken Coleman's book the proximity
principle man I love how his book just
really takes you down the road
from from step one to you know step
fifty on how to really get going in a
career that you really really love I
think he kind of wrote the book I wish
we would have written about how to help
people change their careers he does a
really good job getting you to ask for
right questions which is beautiful yeah
absolutely oh and I also got some
voicemail comments and tips from our
listeners here Josh check them out
hey Joshua and Ryan I do find a lot of
value in the minimalist and I wanted to
share with the listeners two apps that I
use in regards to clothing
number one is Rent the Runway it's an
app that you can rent formal dresses and
accessories the cool thing about them is
they send you two dresses in two
different sizes to ensure that you will
find the best fit and you can see photos
of real people wearing the dress to help
you decide what will work best for you
it's perfect for weddings or special
occasions so you don't have to buy and
write them and number two is a thread up
it's another app that buys and sells
gently used item they send you a prepaid
postage clean out bag that you can fill
up with your unwanted items and you can
get cash for those items or use the
credit to purchase a new to you
item that you would find value in it's
the perfect way to get rid of items that
you no longer need and to purchase a
gently used new to you I bonus you can
return items that don't fit or you don't
like I personally try to use it like a
storage locker so you can get rid of the
things that you don't want anymore
by some use you things and when those
things aren't working anymore or you're
not finding value in send them back as
well for cash or credit the only
negative thing about Rent the Runway or
thredUP
apps is sorry Joshua and Ryan they don't
have men's items but thread up does so
children's gently used items so that's a
great option for a busy mom like me
thank you so much and keep up the good
work
hey guys this message is from Steve in
Palm Beach Gardens Florida I have a
minimalism tip I would like to share
with my fellow listeners I'm in the
process of becoming a Mentalist
I am constantly evaluating my
possessions and discerning my wants for
my needs as well as questioning the
value that certain items bring to me
personally recently I was on the verge
of selling my beloved custom gibson
es-335 guitar a guitar that I truly
enjoy and use often I was convinced that
this item needed to go however I was
still in the sense I was ready to depart
with one of my most prized possessions
but hesitant the reason I wanted to get
rid of this item is because I have
another electric guitar that I also use
frequently I use both of both of these
guitars often and consider to them to be
what you all refer to as tools as I
began to clean up the guitar and post an
ad on Craigslist I began to look around
at the ridiculous amount of other items
that still occupied my home in that
moment I realized there were an
abundance of items that literally
brought me zero value and meant much
less to me than this guitar I soon began
to truly evaluate my possessions after
taking a few weeks to think more on this
particular item I had I donated and
trashed so many other useless objects in
the process if I had written out a list
of every item I owned and rank them in
order of importance to me there would
have been hundreds below this particular
guitar I learned a valuable lesson in
this process I was so stuck on the idea
of becoming a minimalist and become in
getting rid of things that I forgot who
I was in the process guitars are a big
part of my life so my fellow minimalist
don't get rid of the things that you
know bring you joy
get rid of all the no-brainers first
then if you reach a point where you
realize you still do not want that
particular item maybe you will in fact
still depart from it but for me it was
all the other crap in my life that I
needed
get rid of first not one of the few
items that I truly love all right you
know thanks again to Ken Coleman for
joining us today you can check out his
podcast the Ken Coleman show his book
the proximity principle and follow him
on social media and online Ken Coleman
calm and real quick four right here
right now here's one thing that's going
on in the life of the minimalists I
teach a writing class it's called how to
write better you if you want to learn
how to improve your writing whether you
want to write your first book your next
book or better tweets or better business
emails if you want to just become a
better writer learn how to write better
and how to write better dot or much
better than my website how to write good
calm good good yeah how to write better
org I teach new students they're
everything everyone from like literally
medical doctors to high school students
people who have English as a first
language or even second language I had
quite a few students in there from all
walks of life
I believe the rising tide lifts all
boats I'll help you develop the
knowledge but also the habits to learn
how to write better if you have a
question a comment or a minimalism tip
for our podcast leave us a voicemail for
zero six two one nine seven eight three
nine or send a voice memo to podcast at
the minimalists comm you can comment on
this episode at youtube.com slash the
minimalists if you want our show notes
in your inbox sign up for our e-mail
list over at the minimalists comm you'll
also receive our simple Sunday emails
and for our added value this week let's
listen to a song from Leesville Beck's
new album now back Beck's and I went to
go see him live this past this past week
and Los Angeles down at the Moroccan
in the Arts District it was one of the
most unique shows I've ever been to like
he had no opener which I love because
I'm old and I don't want to have to sit
through an opener and go home it was
early show it was it was a 7 p.m. show
so funny that is like 9 times out of 10
if I don't go to a show because I'm like
a second girl it's like midnight right
well this one you had to be out of there
by 9:45 because they had and so he
started right on time he came out he
started playing songs there was
no opener was just him by himself
playing on piano but he would he was
joking in a way we we could see a lot of
musicians who joke during their set
between songs and stuff but he would
stop mid song and lay man this kind of
reminds me of a Boy George so I like to
start playing something random and it
was it was such a good show I really
loved his last album really enjoyed his
last album it was called twin solitude
but this new album he has out right now
is called new ways so here is a song
from that album
here's hot tears from Leif fullbacks new
album new ways and if you leave here
today with just one message we hope
what's this love people and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all we'll see you next
time
minimus